[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم محمود مراد
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور المباشره تاتينا
من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس على وقع
الاحتجاجات المستمره وترقب لتصريحات
محتمله من الرئيس ماكرون
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
مع استمرار الغموض بشان مستقبل مجموعه
فاجنر
تنقل عن مسؤولين غربيين ان الرئيس الروسي
بوتين بدا عمليه السيطره على فاجنر وبعد
حديث كييف عن صعوبات في الجبهه الشرقيه
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه تقول ان القوات
الروسيه تتقدم في جبهات بالشرق في
وخاركيف
يتوعد بمنع القوات الروسيه من السيطره على
البحر الاسود
استمرار الاحتجاجات والاضطرابات في المدن
الفرنسيه لليوم السادس ماكرون يتراس
اجتماعا مع كبار مسؤولي حكومته لتقييم
الاوضاع والسلطات تعزز اجراءاتها الامنيه
وتحقق فيما وصفته بمحاوله اغتيال استهدفت
رئيس البلديه بضواحي باريس
اشتباكات عنيفه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في ام درمان وفي اجواء
الخرطوم بحري الجيش يؤكد اسقاط مسيره
للدعم السريع وقوات الدعم تعلن اسقاط
مسيره وطائره للجيش نائب رئيس مجلس
السياده يقول للجزيره ان فشل وقف اطلاق
النار مرتبط بغياب اليات التنفيذ الصحيحه
والبعثه الامميه تتحدث عن عواقب انسانيه
وخيمه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الجدل المستمر بعد قرار
ملك منصه تويتر ايلون ماسك الحد من قدره
اصحاب الحسابات غير الموثقه على الوصول
للتغريدات حيث سيكون متاحا لهم قراءه الف
تغريده يوميا فقط و500 للحسابات الجديده
ماسك برر قراره لمواجهه او بمواجهه ما
وصفه باستغلال شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي
لبيانات المنصه
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما هي
خلفيات قرار ايلون ماسك بالحد من قدره
الوصول للتغريدات
85% قالوا ان الخلفيه هي اقتصاديه لدفع
الحسابات بالتوفيق في المقابل على 15%
انها لمواجهه شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي لحفظ
بيانات المستخدمين
[موسيقى]
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه تجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا
[موسيقى]
نقلت صحيفه
عن مسؤولين غربيين قولهم ان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بدا يسيطر على مجموعه
واضافه الصحيفه ان قائد فاجنا
نقل بعض ممتلكاته لموظفه في الاسابيع التي
سبقت التمرد على
ماء او ما قد يعقد الامر على الكرملين
وبحسب ما افادت الصحيفه نقلا عن مسؤولين
فان بريجوجن بنى واحده من اكثر الهيئه
المؤسسيه تعقيدا وغير خاضعه للمساءله
وبحسب مسؤولين غربيين فان العديد من
الصفقات التي ابرمتها فاجنر مع حكومات
افريقيه كانت غير رسميه وتعتمد على
التهريب
من عمان معنى اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده اللواء مرحبا
بك في البدايه هذا التطور الخاص
بمجموعه فاجنر الى اي مدن وجدت هذا الامر
متوقعا ان الدوله الروسيه تسيطر بهذه
السهوله على
المجموعه التي ربما قادت اخطر حركه في
تاريخ روسيا الحديث قبل ايام
يعني هي ليست سيطره كليه بمعنى السيطره
لانه بدايه الاتفاق الذي تم من خلال رئيس
بيلاروسيا لوكاشينكو كان يتضمن بنود منها
ما اعلن عنه ومنها ما لم يعلن عنه ولكن
اهم الامور ان من يرغب بتوقيع العقود مع
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بامكانه ان يبقى
داخل روسيا وهذا يعني
عمليه احداث انشقاق جوهري ورئيسي في القوه
البشريه في شركه فاجنر ومن لا يرغب ويرغب
بالعوده الى اهله كذلك له هذا الخيار
ومعفي من المتابعه اذا تبقت الارقام لم
يتفق عليها بالضبط ما بين خمسه الى ثمان
الاف يمكن ان يكونوا سيذهب الى بيلاروسيا
تم السيطره على الاسلحه الثقيله وتم
استعادتها وسيتم ارسالها الى قوات الحرس
الوطني الذي تم تشكيله خلال السنوات
الماضيه الان تبقى المعضل الماليه المعضل
الماليه استطاع ان ينشئ شبكه معقده خاصه
ان حضور فاقنار في بعض التقارير يقول 30
دوله في افريقيا الشرق الاوسط امريكا
اللاتينيه اتفاقات غير رسميه مع قاده هذه
الدول ومعظمها يتعلق اما بحراسه الشخصيه
رقم واحد او بتدريب الجيوب يبقى السؤال
قائما يبقى السؤال قائمه سياده اللواء هل
سيتمكن الرئيس بوتين من السيطره بشكل كامل
على هذه المجموعه
لا اعتقد ذلك لان دخول الرئيس لوكاشينكو
على الخط
وابداء اهتمام كبير جدا بان تكون ذراع
اليمنى في انتخابات 2024 وفي مواجهه دول
الناتو ودول المحاذيه التي تتخذ مواقف
حاده بولندا ليتوانيا استونيا وبالتالي
اعتقد ان الرئيس
الذي انزل الرئيس بوتين عن الشجره لديه
معارب اخرى في احتواء واحتضان قوات فاغنر
وبالتالي الان منحهم قاعده تبعد 130 كيلو
عن كييف وبالتالي كان جزء منها بقياده
بريجوجن ستكون من نصيب لوكيشنكو وبقيه
الاجزاء ستكون من نصيب روسيا سياده اللواء
ارجو منك ان تبقى معنا في سياق الحرب
المستمره في اوكرانيا قال الرئيس فلاديمير
زيلنسكي ان روسيا لن تسيطر على البحر
الاسود
جاء ذلك خلال زياره لمدينه اوديسيا
الساحليه المطله على البحر الاسود والتي
ارتبط اسم مينائها بصفقه تصدير الحبوب منذ
الحرب الراهنه ميدانيا شهدت عده جبهات
مشتعله هجمات وهجمات مضاده وقد اقرت نائبه
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني بان القوات الروسيه
تتقدم في عده جبهات بالشرق في دنيا
معركه البحر الاسود امواجها عاتيه
وحساباتها الكثيره والمعقده قد تغرق البعض
وتكتب لاخرين السياده عليه من اوديسا اراد
الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي ميرسي ان يسمع
نظيره فلاديمير بوتين جمله مكرره روسيا لن
تسيطر على البحر الاسود ذهب ابعد من ذلك
في تحذيرهم موسكو من مغبه الاقتراب من
شواطئ شبه جزيره القرم القرم تحت الصياده
الروسيه منذ 2014 وان ابت كيف والغرب
الاعتراف بذلك تضمن جدول زياره زيلينسكي
للمدينه الساحليه الاستراتيجيه قياده
القوات البحريه واطلع على عمليات قوات
بلاده وايضا القدرات الصاروخيه الروسيه
قباله السواحل الاوكرانيه خلال الشهر
الماضي اعلنت موسكو صده هجوم اوكراني
بالقوارب السريعه على احدى سفن اسطولها في
البحر الاسود باعتراف وسائل اعلام غربيه
القواعد الروسيه في جزيره القرم منحت
موسكو تفوقا عسكريا على حلف شمال الاطلس
في البحر الاسود تبقى مياه البحر في
المنطقه مضطربه ورهن حسابات الربح
والخساره على اليابسه في اوكرانيا واتفاق
تصدير الحبوب قد يلفظ انفاسه الاخيره بعد
الثامن عشر من يوليو الجاري في حال تشبثت
موسكو بموقفها السبب يعود وفق وزير
الخارجيه الروسي السرجي الى موقف الغرب
المخزي من الصفقه على حد تعبيره اشار
تحديدا الى الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
وفي وقت لمنتصر فيه ولا منهزمه في هذا
النزاع تستمر المعارك في اكثر من جبهه
مشتعله ينسب كل طرف الى نفسه احباط هجوم
الطرف الاخر تقول المتحدثه باسم قياده
عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه ان القتال في
خرسون معقد ولكن قوات بلادها كبدت الخصم
الكثير من الخسائر في المقابل نشرت وسائل
اعلام روسيه رسميه صور استهداف اليات
عسكريه اوكرانيه في جبهات دونيات انتحاريه
لم ينجلي دون اطلاق صافرات الانذار اعلنت
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت ليلا
طائرات مسيره مسلحه في اول هجوم روسي على
العاصمه خلال 12 يوما برا وبحرا وجوا هجوم
وهجوم مضاد دوامه الصراع المسلح لا تهدا
ولا مواكب الجنازات تتوقف وسط انقاض حرب
تحالفات عالميه على الارض الاوكرانيه
اعود الى ضيفنا اللواء فايز دويري الخبير
والعسكري والاستراتيجي من عمان سياده
اللواء الروس يتقدمون على اربع جبهات بما
يعني ان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد ربما لا
يسير على النحو الذي كان مخططا من اجله
الجانب الاوكراني يرجى سبب هذا التعثر الى
المماطله من قبل الغرب في تدريب طياره على
طائرات اف 16 ويرجع ذلك ايضا الى تقاعس
بعض البلدان الغربيه في امداد بلاده
بالاسلحه ما مدى وجاهت هذه الذريعه
يعني اعتقد ان هناك اسباب لم يتحدث عنها
الجانب الاوكراني انا هنا اتحدث من منظور
عسكري بحث اولا هناك نقاط ايجابيه استطاع
الجيش الروسي ان يحققها اولا استطاع ان
يبني شبكه دفاعات وخطه الدفاعيه في بعض
الحالات ثلاثه خطوط دفاعيه في بعض المناطق
والخط واقل من ذلك في المناطق الاخرى
والخط الدفاعي الاول في بعض المناطق وصل
عمقه الى خمسه كيلومترات اثنين اجاد اجاد
بناء التنظيم الدفاعي في الخط الواحد على
سبيل المثال اذا نظرنا الى منطقه زبروجيه
نجد للخط الدفاعي حقول الغام خندق ضد
الدبابات مواقع دفاعيه معزز باسلحه ممدال
وقوات احتياط محلي من اجل الهجمات السريعه
اداره المعركه مختلف كلا عن كليا عن معركه
خاركيف اجبرت القوات الاوكرانيه ان تقاتل
على كل متر تريد السيطره عليه يضاف الى
ذلك منظومه العمل الاستخباري الروسي ابدت
نوع من المهاره اكثر مما كان سابقا بحيث
بدات تستطيع الحصول على معلومه تحدد مناطق
الحجز والتجمع وطرق التقرب واوقعت القوات
الاوكرانيين في اكثر من كمين مما ادى الى
تدمير دبابات لبارد والفرنسيه ام اكس
وغيرها من الاليات يقابل ذلك الجانب
الاوكراني يتحدث للانصاف عن مرحله تمهيديه
اي انه لم يزج
بالاحتياط الاستراتيجي والقوه الرئيسيه
لتنفيذ الهجوم
والمرحله التمهيديه اذا اخذناها من بعد
نظر تحليلي هي مرحله من خلال اسمها
المرحله التمهيديه هي تهيئ ارض المعركه من
اجل انجاح الهجوم الرئيسي هذا النجاح لم
يتحقق بالمطلق ولكنه استطاع ان يحقق لا
نستطيع ان ننكر انها حققت الكثير في محيط
وفي منطقه
وسيطرت على اكثر من 130 كيلو متر لكن هذه
النجاحات لم ترقى الى مستوى
بايذاء المعطيات الراهنه سياده اللواء
حينما توعد زيلينسكي الجانب الروسي بانه
لن يتمكن او لن يسمح له بالسيطره على
البحر الاسود هل هذا ممكن في ظل المعطيات
الراهنه
لا في ظل المعطيات الراهنه اذا كان يتحدث
عن البحريه الاوكرانيه هذا غير ممكن ولكن
هو ومن خلال تقارير سابقه الحديث عن تواجد
البحريه الامريكيه وبحريه النيتو من منظور
ان شواطئ حلف الناتو على البحر الاسود
اطول جغرافيا من شواطئ روسيا على البحر
الاسود منذ عام 2000 منذ عام 2014 بدات
تحركات امريكيه لا يوجد تواجد امريكي دائم
في البحر الاسود لا يوجد قوه امريكيه
بحريه مخصصه للبحر الاسود لكن هي تدخل من
ممر البسفور وفي ارقى الحالات وصلت الى
قطعتين بحريتين مدمره وفرقاطه وفي احد
المرات شاركت حامل الطائرات المجمل
البحريه المحيطه على البحر الاسود لحلف
الناتو اذا اخرجنا البحريه الامريكيه
واضحه جدا اكبرها البحريه التركيه
والبحريه التركيه هي تخضع استخدامها يخضع
الاعتبارات سياسيه هناك
اتفاقيات هناك الاس 400 وبالتالي لا يمكن
المراهنه على قلب الصفحه التركيه لتكون
بتوافق مطلق مع الناتو ضد روسيا شكرا
جزيلا لك سياده اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كان معنا من
عمان
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا حيث قالت وسائل الاعلام ان
الاجتماع الذي عقده الرئيس ايمانويل
ماكرون برئيسه الوزراء وسبعه من اعضاء
الحكومه انتهى بعد ان دام ساعه ونصف وعقد
الاجتماع لبحث اجراءات حازمه لتطويق موجه
العنف التي رافقت الاحتجاجات التي تلت
مقتل شاب من اصول جزائريه بنيران شرطي
الاسبوع الماضي كانت الرئاسه الفرنسيه قد
قالت ان الاجتماع يهدف لتقييم الوضع
لاتخاذ القرارات المناسبه
وقد فتحت السلطات تحقيقا فيما وصفتها
بمحاوله اغتيال كانت تستهدف رئيس بلديه
ليروز بمقاطعه دماغ
وقالت مصادر الفرنسيه ان مجهولين هاجموا
منزل رئيس البلديه بسياره اشعل فيها النار
ما اسفر عن اصابه زوجه رئيس البلديه
ونقلها الى المستشفى وزاره رئيسه الوزراء
الفرنسيه اليزابيث بون يرافقها وزير
الداخليه زارت بلديه ليروز واعربا عن
تضامنهما مع رئيس البلديه
هذا وقد دعت جده الفتى الفرنسي من اصول
جزائريه الذي قتل برصاص شرطين يوم
الثلاثاء الماضي دعت الى وقف اعمال العنف
وطلبت الجده ناديه في اتصال هاتفي مع قناه
بي اف ام تي في المحليه طلبت مني يكسرون
واجهات المحلات والحافلات والمدارس
بالتوقف عن افعالهم واوضحت ان بعض
المتظاهرين يتخذون من حادثه نائل وسيله
للتكسير والعنف وقالت ان فرنسا بحاجه الى
العوده الى الهدوء على حد تعبيرها
معنا من باريس مراسل الجزيره لطفي
المسعودي لطفي هذا تقريبا هو اليوم السابع
منذ وقوع الحادثه ضعنا في تفاصيل المشهد
الامني
محمود
وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه تتحدث عن بعض
اعمال التخريب في مدن متفرقه ولكنها تقول
انها يعني منسوب العنف لا يمكن مقارنته
حتى بما جد ليله الامس ولكنها تركز على
هذا الاجتماع الذي دعم اكثر من ساعه ونصف
بين ماكرون
وسبعه من وزرائه حتى وان لم يصدر اي بيان
بشان مخرجاته الى حد الان وتقول ان رمزيه
الثواني الثمانيه عشر التي خرجت من صور من
هذا الاجتماع تريد ايصال رساله مفادها
الوحده والحزم داخل هذه الحكومه في مواجهه
موجه العنف الحضري المستعر في فرنسا منذ
سته ايام محمود
وان لم يصدر اي بيان بشان مخرجات الاجتماع
الى حد الان فمن الواضح ان هذا اللقاء
الذي لم يكن مبرمجا في اجنده الرئيس ياتي
لاحاطته من قبل وزرائه بالوضع الامني في
البلاد وجدوى الخطوات التي اتخذت لمجابهته
وتلك المزمع اتخاذها والتي يمكن قراءتها
فيما نقلته صحيفه لوموند عن مصادر خاصه من
ان وزير الداخليه الفرنسي جيرال درمنا
اصدر تعليمات حازمه وشدد على ضروره ان يتم
تنفيذ الاعتقالات بحق مرتكبي اعمال العنف
والنهب والتخريب باسرع وقت كما يمكن كذلك
قراءتها في الاحكام التي صدرت بحق من تم
اعتقالهم وتقديمهم سريعا للقضاء وصدرت
بحقهم احكام اليوم يعني
هنالك نوع من التغيير في استراتيجيه تعامل
السلطات الفرنسيه مع موجه العنف هذه من
خلال التسريع بالاعتقال والمحاكمه من اجل
يعني حشر من تعتبرهم بالعناصر المشاغبه في
السجون في اطار استراتيجياتها لتهدئه
الاوضاع وذلك بالدفع اكثر بوحدات امنيه
متخصصه الى الشارع
مع توالي فصول هذه الازمه صعدت مطالبات
بفرض حاله الطوارئ والاحكام العرفيه وحظر
التجول احيانا من قبل حراس المحلات او
اصحاب المحل التجاريه والمتاجر الفاخره
بايذاء الوضع الذي تقول انه بدا في الهدوء
ولا يمكن مقارنه العنف الذي سجل اليوم
بالايام الماضيه هل توارت هذه الدعوات او
انتهى الحديث عن الطوارئ
بالنسبه لمساله الحديث عن حاله الطوارئ
يبدو انه حسب استطلاعات الراي طبعا محمود
يبدو انه بات مطلبا شعبيا لان الاستبيانات
تقول ان قرابه 69 في المئه من الشعب
الفرنسي يطالب بفرض حاله الطوارئ ولكن ان
كان الرئيس ووزرائه قد قرروا هذا الامر
لكان قد خرج سريعا لان هذه الامور اذا ما
اتخذت تعلن فورا ولكن يبدو ان ماكرون
ووزرائه مقتنعون بان الوحدات الامنيه هي
بصدد تحقيق نجاحات لان منسوب العمق بين
ليله واخرى ينزل تدريجيا
والسلطات الفرنسيه تدفع بتشكيلات
متخصصه من القوات
المحترفه في مكافحه الشغب وحتى في مكافحه
الارهاب دفعت بها للتعامل مع هذه الاح
تجاجات ويبدو انها في تقديرها تحقق نجاحات
وتامل في ان
يعود الهدوء قريبا الى فرنسا محمود لطفي
المسعودي من باريس شكرا جزيلا لك
هذا وقد ابقى وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه على
نفس عدد القوات الامنيه المنتشره في كافه
انحاء البلاد لهذه الليله والمقدر عددهم
بخمسه
وطالب الوزير في اجتماع امني قوات الامن
بالحزم وعدم التردد في اجراء توقيفات وحسب
المعلومات فان الشرطه الفرنسيه ستستخدم
الطائرات المسيره في باريس وضاحيه اعالي
السان غرب العاصمه من السادسه مساء اليوم
وحتى السادسه صباح الغد تفاصيل المشهد
الميداني في المدن الفرنسيه في التقرير
التالي
تاكيد رئيسه الحكومه الفرنسيه ان اجهزه
الدوله كامله ستعمل بقوه لوقف العنف
واستعاده النظام يبدو انه اثمر بعض الشيء
دون ان يحصد هدوءا كاملا فلا يزال الغضب
المتراكم ماثلا في شوارع البلاد من الشمال
الى الجنوب
العاصمه الفرنسيه تشهد انتشار سبعه الاف
شرطي بحسب تاكيد قائد الشرطه الذي يقول ان
عناصره سيمارسون الحزم مع كل منتهك
للقانون مهما كانت اصوله وعلى وقع هذه
المعطيات تراجعت اعمال الشغب نسبيا في قلب
باريس وضواحيها في وسط البلاد وقعت مواجهه
عنيفه بين الشرطه وشبان صاحبتها عمليات
حرق لنقاط تحصنت فيها الشرطه مدينه نيس
السياحيه جنوب شرقي فرنسا
تدخلت الشرطه باستخدام مدرعات وغاز مسير
للدموع لتفريق محتجين ولوقف نهب المحال
التجاريه حسب ما قالت
الى مارسي جنوبيه البلاد حيث اعتقلت
الشرطه عشرات الاشخاص بعدما عززت قواتها
هناك يبدو المشهد في موبيليا اكثر حده حيث
استخدمت الشرطه الغاز المسيله للدموع في
مواجهه متظاهرين اما التطورات في ليل روز
في مقاطعه فالدومارا فكانت على مستويات
اكثر خطوره النيابه العامه فتحت تحقيقا
فيما وصفتها بمحاوله اغتيال كانت تستهدف
رئيس البلديه اذ هاجم مجهولون منزله
باستخدام سياره واشعل فيها النار الشرطه
الفرنسيه نشرت ما يقرب من 45 الف شرطي
ودركي في انحاء البلاد والافا من رجال
الاطفاء مع تعزيزات خاصه الى ثلاث مدن
رئيسيه هي باريس واليوم ومارساي في واحده
من اسوا ازم ات البلاد منذ اعاده انتخاب
ايمانويل ماكرون لعهده ثانيه
وفي احدث احصائيه لاول اربعه ايام من
الاحتجاجات اعتقلت الشرطه نحو 900 شخص
واصيب اكثر من 500 شرطي وعنصر درك بينما
نشب اكثر من
20600 حريق وتضرر اكثر من 800 مبنى ونحو
اربعه الاف مركبه احترقت بينما وصل الضرر
لنحو 700 محل تجاري على امتداد البلاد ومع
استمرار الاحتجاجات فانه من المبكر قياس
حجم الخسائر المباشره التي منيت بها فرنسا
نتيجه الاضطرابات التي تلت قتل شرطي الفتى
نائل المرزوقي والاصعب بالتاكيد قياس
الخسائر الاجتماعيه غير الماديه على
البلاد والتي يخشى ان تاثيراتها ستضرب
عميقا في الجغرافيا الاجتماعيه الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
معنا من باريس السيد
الباحث في المعهد الاوروبي للاستشرافي
والامن ومن نورماندي في شمال فرنسا السيده
ان اليزابيث
الصحفيه والكاتبه في صحيفه التلغراف
البريطانيه مرحبا بكم وابدا مع السيده
اليزابيث
كتبتي مقالا تحت عنوان العالم يشاهد وهو
لا يكاد يصدق فرنسا وهي تمزق نفسها اليس
في هذا العنوان مبالغه بعض الشيء في نهايه
المطاف فرنسا مرت عليها ازمات ربما اخطر
من هذه مثل حادثه الضواحي وانتفاضه
الضواحي في 2005 وغيرها وتجاوزت الامور
واستطاعت لملمه جراحها كما انه
الوقائع او المعطيات على الارض تشير الى
ان قوات الامن بدات في استيعاب واحتواء
موجه العنف هذه
حين يكون لدينا اعمال عنف
ليست خلال قضيه سياسيه وليس لديها تعبير
فعلي وتبدا بالقول نحن نعامل بطريقه سيئه
ونقتل اطفالنا هذا امر مفهوم ولكن حين
ينتهي الامر بتخريب
وناهب يقولون نحن جياع ومن ثم يدمرون
حينداك يكون لدينا ازمه ليس فقط ازمه
حاليه ثوره تمرد
بمئات المليارات من اليورو التي انفقت
مرافق
ومع ذات وزعت على تلك المناطق من اجل ان
لا يترك الشبان والشابات
لوحدهم لدينا مستشفيات مراكز رياضيه مراكز
اجتماعيه كل ذلك قد دمر ونشعر بان هناك
تدمير اعتقد انها ازمه مشكله ازمه بسبب
التعليم والخدمات
لدينا عدم احترام للدوله للديمقراطيه ايضا
فعلا انا اعتبر ان البلاد تنفجر
الان وقد تراجع مستوى العنف ربما لم يعد
هناك حاجه في نظر الحكومه على الاقل لفرض
حاله الطوارئ هل تعتقد انه بعد هدوء هذه
العاصفه ينبغي على الحكومه ان تشرع في
معالجه او مقاربه جديده او مختلفه لمساله
حاله الضواحي
ومساله التمييز العنصري حسب اتهام الامم
المتحده
اصلا ليس هناك تمييز عنصري في فرنسا جميع
المواطنين يعملون بطريقه نفسها والا كيف
يمكننا ان نبرر انه داخل قوى الامن لدينا
اشخاص اجانب
المتحدثه باسم الدرك هي تاتي من اصلا من
المغرب وهي برتبه كولونيل وبالتالي لما
وصلت الى منصبها لو كان هناك فعلا عنصري
يعني هذه عفوا للمقاطعه فقط لان هذه الحجه
مردود عليها باكثر من وجه هذه الحجه تفتقر
الى المنطق مساله وجود عناصر في الشرطه
يرجعون الى اصول المهاجرين يعني لعلك تعرف
ان في الى جواركم المملكه المتحده فيها
وزير الداخليه ووزيره الداخليه قبلها
ورئيس للحكومه كلهم يرجعون الى اصول
مهاجره لكن تبدو سياستهم الاكثر عداء
للمهاجرين على مر تاريخ المملكه المتحده
فهذه ليست حجه في نهايه المطاف تفضل
اعتقد ان هناك تمييز عنصر عنصري بما انه
لدينا شخص من اصل اجنبي قادر على الوصول
الى مناصب رافعه مستوى هناك الكثير من
الوزراء من اصول اجنبيه في الحكومه في قوى
الامن التمييز عنصري هو نعتبر الشخص الاخر
اقل منا وبالتالي عمل على هذه الطريقه
الاشخاص الذين يتعرضون لتوقيفات اكثر من
اصول اجنبيه لاسباب واضحه لانه بحسب
الاحصاءات الجرميه لدينا اشخاص من اصول
مغربيه افريقيه المانيا وغيرها ليست مساله
وصول اثنيه او عرقيه او عنصريه لانه لدينا
عدد من المجرمين اكبر من هذه الجنسيات او
من هذه الاصول الشخص الذي توفي كان لديه
ايضا توابق ليس ملاكا كما قال
اللاعب الفرنسي يجب ان نتوقف عن القول ان
هناك تمييز عنصري اعتقد ان هذا الكلام عن
وجود ضحيه هو الذي يجعلنا لا نعالج الامور
فعليا اقولها مره اخرى يمكن لاي كان ان
يصل الى المناصب المختلفه في فرنسا
كلامك هذا عين
ما يتخذ كلامك هذا وطريقه التفكير هذه
ربما هي عين ما يتخذ ذريعه للمضي قدما في
اعمال الاحتجاجات يعني ربما يعتبره غيره
غيرك كلاما فيه شيء من العنصريه وفي شيء
من التجنيه على المنحدرين من اصول
المهاجره دعنا نستطلع رايي السيده
اليزابيث الان في هذا الصدد سيدنا اليسا
هل توافقين على ما جاء في كلام ضيفنا او
في مداخله ضيفنا
شيئا خاطئا هناك في فرنسا الكثير من
الوزراء الذين لديهم اصول مغربيه رشيده
ذاتي في وزاره العدل
سنغاليه ايضا ايضا رئيس مجلس الشيوخ كان
من
الفرنسيه بين سب العام 1947 و 1969 حصل
ذلك اكثر من مره وبتمكن ان نتحدث عن
انكسار في هيكليه
الهيكليه الفرنسيه في الولايات المتحده
هناك قراءه امريكيه محدوده وهذا يختلف عن
فرنسا هل هذا يعني ان فرنسا ليس لدي هذا
المشاكل هناك فرنسيون يمارسون التلاميذ
العنصري ولكن
توجيه تهمه تمييز العنصري المنهجي غير
صحيح
هناك الكثير من هؤلاء الشبان الذين يمكنهم
ان ينجحوا ولكن لا اعتقد ان هذا مستحيل في
الوقت نفسه
نحن لا نختمهم حنا نضعهم في مدارس ومؤسسات
تعليميه لا يتعلمون كيف يجدون او ما يجب
ان يتعلموا ليجدوا فرص عمل ملائمه طيب
برايك ما هي الاستراتيجيه التي ينبغي على
الرئيس ماكرون وحكومته ان يتبعوها لتجاوز
هذه المشكله وحلها بشكل جذري بعد هدوء
العاصفه الراهنه
السؤال لك سيده الى
اولا نحن بحاجتنا الهدوء وانتم محقون سيدي
هذا اولا ثانيا يجب ان ننظر الى المبلغ
الماليه التي خصصت للضواحيها للاسف يبدو
انها لم تنفع كثيرا نتحدث عن 150 مليار
يورو بين العام 2015
تتحدث عن
اذا معدات وتجهيزات لم تؤتي ثمارها
المشكله هي ان الاندماج الذي نحن نسعى
اليه لكي يكون على اشخاص جزءا من هذا
المجتمع لاسيما ان الشباب الاذكى هم
يدركون اهميه ذلك في هذا الحاله نحن بحاجه
الى نوع من اتفاقيه سلام بين اسر محترمه
هذا مجتمعيين محترمين لديهم هيبه لدى
المنظمات لدى المجموعات الكبيره حتى نقول
يجب ان ندخل معاهده سلام حيث مثلا اطفالي
يدرسون في المدرسه
توفر لهم المدرسه الحصص الاضافيه لا ياتي
الاهل ويشتكون من تدني الدرجات والعلامات
المدرسه
وحين ذلك
لا يعود الاهل يطالبون بان يعاملوا على
انهم ملائكه مع انهم ليسوا ملائكه
شكرا جزيلا لك يا السيده
الصحفيه وكاتبه العمود في صحيفه
واشكر ضيفنا من باريس السيد بيير
الباحث في المعهد الاوروبي للاستشراف
[موسيقى]
استمرت المواجهات في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وقالت قوات الدعم السريع انها
اسقطت طائره حربيه من طراز ميك من جهته
اعلن الجيش السوداني انه اسقط طائره مسيره
تتبع قوات الدعم السريع فيما يجري الحديث
عن اشتباكات عنيفه في ام درمان وقال الملك
عقار نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
الذي يزور اثيوبيا ان سبب فشل المحاولات
لوقف اطلاق النار هو افتقارها لاليات
التنفيذ الصحيحه وفي ظل استمرار المعارك
تدق المنظمات الدوليه ناقوس الخطر وتقول
ان الوضع الانساني يزداد سوءا
في غياب اي افق للحل تتحول الحرب في
السودان الى واقع اكثر ما يخيف فيه هو ان
يطول تتركز المعارك في ام درمان التي شهدت
اشتباكات عنيفه بين قوات الجيش ومسلحي
الدعم السريع
ياتي هذا بعد ان اعلن عضو مجلس السياده
بالسودان ياسر العطاء ان العمليات
العسكريه بامدرمان ستؤدي لانهاء التمرد
وان القوات الخاصه في الجيش تنفذ عمليات
في مناطق ام درمان وتطوق من وصفهم بعناصر
من الجنجويد في عدد من احيائها وفي تطور
لافت في الخرطوم بحري في الجهه المقابله
من النيل يعلن الجيش انه اسقطا مسيره
تابعه لقوات الدعم السريه كانت تستهدف
منطقه بحر العسكريه بينما تقول قوات الدعم
السريع انها اسقطت طائره حربيه من طراز
ميغ تابعه للجيش ومسيره في ظل هذه الاجواء
يتوجه مالك عقار نائب رئيس مجلس سيادته
الى اديس ابابا للمره الثانيه خلال الشهر
ومن هناك يتحدث عقار عما يراه سببا لفشل
محاولات وقف اطلاق النار
كبير في السودان في حياه الناس والبنيه
التحتيه معاناه كبيره لحقت بالمدنيين
وبالموارد وحقوق الانسان هناك كثير من
الوسطات بينها المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه ولقد خلصت بالفعل الفجوه قليلا
لكن هذه المبادرات تفتقر لاليات التنفيذ
الصحيحه لقد كانت هناك هدن كثيره لكنها لم
تنجح مالك عقار اوضح الصوره ايضا بالنسبه
لادوار محتمله لقوات فاجنر الروسيه في
السودان
قوته في السودان لكنها موجوده في عدد من
الدول المجاوره وفي المناطق الحدوديه
اعتقد ان لديها ايضا العديد من الاتفاقات
مع دول مجاوره لنا في السودان قد تكون لها
علاقه بقوات الدعم السريع لكن على مستوى
الاستثمارات هذا ما يقال
تدور المعارك بالاساس بين قوات الجيش
ومسلح الدعم السريع لكن طرفا ثالثا هو
قوات الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان
بقياده عبد العزيز الحلو يتحول تدريجيا
الى فاعل اساسي في الحرب قال مصدر عسكري
في الجيش ان سلاح الجو نفد لليوم الثاني
على التوالي طلعات لضرب تجمعات هذه القوات
في كردفان وقال مصدر من الحركه ان قواتها
سيطرت على حاميه عبري وتحدثت مصادر من
الجيش عن انسحاب تكتيكي منها الى حاميه
دلامي دون خسائر تثير كل هذه التطورات
مخاوفه من ان يتحول النزاع في السودان الى
حرب استنزاف يدفع ثمنها الشعب السوداني في
البدايه والنهايه
معنا هنا في الاستوديو الاستاذ عادل الباز
الكاتب والمحلل السياسيه السوداني استدعى
المرحبا بك مرحبا الملك عقار يتحدث من
الديسابا عن افتقار المبادرات لوقف اطلاق
النار للاليات الصحيحه لانزال هذه
المبادره على ارض الواقع ماذا يعني
بالاليات الصحيحه
طرحت من خلال المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه
اكثر من هدنه واكثر من رؤيه لوقف القتال
ولكن افتقدت هذه
المبادرات لاليات على الارض التحقق من من
ينتهك الهدن من
يعني يستولي على المستشفيات من يدخل
المنازل المواطنين لا ليس هناك اليه او
لجنه او اي جهه تتحقق ولذلك ظلت الدعاه من
الطرفين من هذا خرج الهدنه ان هذا هو الذي
انتهك الاتفاق ولذلك
قوات اضافيه للتحقق من الانتهاكات هل
معطيات المعارك على ارض الواقع يعني بحاجه
او ينقصها نشر قوات اضافيه ايضا طبعا لا
يمكن نشر قوات اضافيه في هذا الوقت لكن
كان المقترح ليان حتى لجان مدنيه كونت
لجنه مدنيه من الاطباء لتذهب الى التحقق
من وجود قوات الدعم السريع في المستشفيات
ولكن قوات الدعم السريع حين ذهبت هذه
اللجنه رفضت دخول هذه اللجنه الى هذه
النوع من الليان الذي كان يمكن ان تستوصف
على ارض الواقع وتحت حمايه مثلا الصليب
الاحمر لتبعث التقارير الى المفوضين في
جده ولكن
الطرف من الاطراف ورفض التعامل مع هذه
اللجنه وجود السيد مالك عقار عقار في
ديسبابا هل يعني ولو بصوره ضمنيه انفتاحا
على مزيد من المقترحات او المبادرات
القادمه من الاتحاد الافريقي او من
يعني الشركاء الاقليميين ان صح هذا
التعبير بدلا من مبادره الايجاد التي لقيت
رفضا سريعا من الجانب السوداني الاتحاد
الافريقي اعلن خطه اسمها خطه خفض التصعيد
وهي تتكون من خمسه نقاط وبدا الحوار حولها
ولكن بعض ظهور مبادره الايجاد توقف الحوار
حوله انا لا ادري اذا كان
سيعيد هذا الحوار مع الاتحاد الافريقي حول
مبادره خفض
التحفظ عليها لانه ليس عضوا في اتحاد
الافريقي ولم يتم التشاور معه
اثيوبيا
بالذات هي مركز من مراكز القرار الافريقي
اهم مركز يعني بها الاتحاد الافريقي وكل
المجلس الامن والسلم الافريقي موجود ولذلك
هذه منطقه تحتاج الى عمل كثير دبلوماسي
كثير مع كل الاطراف الموجوده وهم لاعبين
اساسيين في الملف
الجيش اليوم يقول انه اسقط مسيره لقوات
الدعم السريع وقوات الدعم السريع تقول
انها اسقطت الطائره ميجو ومسيره تابعه
لقوات الجيش هل بلغنا جديدا من العنف
والصراع لاحظ
يعني باستمرار تعلن انها المليشه تعلم
انها اسقطت الطائره وهي لا تملك مضادات
طائرات مثل
هذه تتعطل وتضغط يعني اما الطائره التي
المسيره التي اسقطت رايناها في الفيديوهات
وكثير من المسيرات اضغطها اصغرتها
لقوات القوات المسلحه وكثير من
[موسيقى]
الاجهزه الاخرى صناعه الجيش يعني
اين النخب السياسيه السودانيه وقوى
المجتمع المدني من احداث احداث هذه تجري
على ارض السودان ام انه عندما يعلو صوت
المدافع تختفي السياسه بالضبط هذا ما يحصل
للنخب النخب تتصارع وتجعل الحروب ثم عندما
تبدا صوت البنادق تختفي من
وتنتظر المنتصر
لتسيير في ركبه اليه ولكن مثل هذه الاوقات
الذي يحتاج فيها الشعب لمسانده النخب
الشعب الان يساند رواته المسلحه النخب
السياسيه التي كانت تتزارع طيله الفان
اختفت من الساحه السياسيه ودع اهدا دائما
حين يجد الجد وحين
تبدا الحرب في اي مكان يلزون بالصمت شكرا
جزيلا لك الاستاذ عادل الباز الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني شكرا لك
نبقى في السودان حيث حذرت السلطات الصحيه
بوادي حلفا من خطوره الاوضاع الصحيه
للاطفال في مراكز ايواء النازحين بسبب
تفشي الامراض والنقص الكبير في الادويه
ونشدت السلطات المنظمات الدوليه ومنظمه
رعايه الطفوله اليونسيف نشادتها الاسراع
في تقديم المساعدات الطبيه والغذائيه لهم
وتمتنع الجزيره عن بث صور لاطفال مرضى
نظرا لقساواتها
[موسيقى]
ريان طفله في ربيعها الثاني
تراجع وضعها الصحي منذ اسبوع بسبب التهاب
واسهال حاد
ولم يتحسن حالها رغم تناولها بعد العقاقير
يستبد القلق بوالدتها بسبب نقصان وزن
ابنتها وعدم حصولها على الادويه اللازمه
نبتدي عيانا المستشفى لقينا الادويه ما
لقينا الادويه في نفس المستشفى وقال لي
انا امشي اصرفهم من بره بعد مشينا صرفت
الدواء جبتها هنا السخانه الشديده والدواء
هنا فسدت
حالات مماثله كثيره سجلت في مراكز الايواء
بوادي حلفا حيث تتفشى امراض مختلفه
تلوث المياه ودرجه الحراره المرتفعه في
هذا الجزء من البلاد تسبب في امراض عده
لدى الاطفال بينها الحساسيه
مشينا المستشفيات عشان انقلع علاجنا يوقف
الاسهال والاستفراغ ما لقيناه تعبنا شديد
مستشفى وادي حلفا يستقبل يوميا اعدادا
كبيره من الاطفال المرضى بينهم حالات حريه
تحتاج الى علاج مستمر وبعضهم حديث الولاده
يتطلب وضعهما الصحي فحوصا متقدمه لا تتوفر
في هذا المستشفى
في اطفال بيكونوا هنا موجودين في العياده
بتشنجوا ما في ادويه اليوم يعني الصيدليه
تكاد تكون خاليه من ادويه الاطفال
البنادول البنادول غير موجود
فيعني تعتبر كارثه خصوصا انه عدد الاطفال
كبير لا يقفوا حجم الماسات عند هذا الحد
فمئات الاطفال لم يتلقوا التطعيمات ضد
الامراض والاوبئه بينما يحتاج اخرون الى
اجراء عمليات جراحيه قد لا تتوفر في
البلاد بسبب الحرب وصعوبه العبور الى مصر
في ظل التعقيدات الاداريه المرتبطه
بالحصول على التاشيره تفشل الامراض
وانعدام الرعايه الصحيه ينذران بحجم الخطر
الذي يحدق بالاطفال النازحين وضع قد يزداد
سوءا ما لم يتحرك المجتمع الدولي للحد من
هذا النزيف اطاهر المرضي الجزيره من وادي
حلفا بالولايه الشماليه
[موسيقى]
صدقت اسرائيل على شراء السر بن ثالث من
الطائرات المقاتله المتطوره من طراز اف 35
في صفقه قيمتها ثلاثه مليارات دولار هذه
الصفقه تعيد تسليط الضوء على التسلح
الاسرائيلي المتسارع والمكثف بالتزامن مع
حديث اسرائيل المتكرر عن حرب محتمله على
عده جبهات وعليه تتهيا اسرائيل لاقتناء 25
مقاتله من طراز اف 35 الاكثر تطورا في
العالم ذات القدره القتاليه الهائله وهو
ما يكرس وضعها كجهه وحيده تملك تلك
الطائرات في الشرق الاوسط ضمن ما تسميه
واشنطن التزامها بضمان تفوق اسرائيل
العسكري وبتنفيذ الصفقه الجديده خلال
الاشهر القليله المقبله ستوسع اسرائيل
اسطولها الجوي من هذه المقاتلات الى 75
طائره وهو عدد لا تملكه غير الولايات
المتحده البلد المصنع تمام كما يملك الجيش
الاسرائيلي واحده من اكثر تطورا وتنوعا في
المنطقه من مقاتله اف 15 واف سته عشر
الامريكيه المتطوره ايضا والصواريخ
والمنظومات الدفاعيه كما ان بحوزه اسرائيل
منظومات صاروخيه متطوره بينها الصاروخه
اريحا واحد واثنان البالستيان اللذان
طورتهما بالشراكه مع فرنسا ويصل مدى الاول
الى ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه الى نحو السته
الاف وخمسمائه كيلو متر وتتكامل تلك
المنظومات مع فرسانه بريه قويه وهو ما
يجعلها قوه هجوميه بالاساس لا دفاعيه
طائره اف 35 هي من مقاتلات الجيل الخامس
التي صممت لتكون طائره هيمنه جويه بقدرات
شبحيه وتملكها الى جانب اسرائيل حتى الان
دول قليله خارج النيتو في بدايه العام
الراهن توصلت كندا الى اتفاق مع الولايات
المتحده لشراء 88 طائره اف 35 تتسلمها على
مراحل بدءا من عام 2026 وعام 2020 وافقت
الولايات المتحده على بيع اليابان وخمس من
مقاتلات شبح اف 35 في صفقه تقدر قيمتها
بحوالي 23 مليار دولار
كما يملك جيش كوريا الجنوبيه نحو 40 طائره
من طراز اف 35 واعلنت سول في مارس اذار
الماضي انها تعتزم شرائع 20 مقاتله اخرى
من تلك الطائرات
كانت استراليا الحليف الوثيق للولايات
المتحده من اولى الدول التي حصلت مبكرا
على مقاتلات 35 حيث يملك سلاحها الجوي
منها اكثر من اربعين طائره
معنى من واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه والعلوم السياسيه
دكتور خليل مرحبا بك
هذه الصفقه هل نستطيع ان نفهمها في سياق
حديث اسرائيل المتكرر عن قرب نشوب حرب في
المنطقه بينها وبين احد جيرانها ايران او
غيره ام تاتي في اطار يعني التزام او
الولايات المتحده بالتفوق وضمان التفوق
الاستراتيجي لاسرائيل على جيرانها
انا اعتقد كلا الامرين معا الامر الاول
متعلق بمخاف اسرائيليه مما يطلق عليه وحده
الساحات خاصه فيما يعني بعد ما حدث قبل
فتره قليله من اشتعال الجبهه الشماليه
الخاصه مع لبنان او ما حدث في غزه
وبالتالي استراليا من وجود حرب شامله في
اكثر من ساحه سواء ساحه السوريه او الساحه
اللبنانيه او الساحه الفلسطينيه وبالتالي
محاوله استباقيه من اجل الرد الامراض
المتعلقه ربما بتفكير اسرائيلي ما في
توجيه ضربات عسكريه الى المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه خاصه بضل الحديث المتزايد حول
امكانيه التواصل الاتفاق بين الطرفين
الامريكي والايراني تظل مفاوضات غير
مباشره برعايه عمانيه على مدار اخر كم
اسبوع وبالتالي محاوله من ايران لا هذه
المساله وقد يقول امرك محمود وهو متعلق
ويطلق عليه كول ايدج كيو ام اي وهو ضمان
التفوق النوعي لاسرائيل في المنطقه
العربيه الاوسط فيما يتعلق بحيازته باسلا
بافضل
واكثر الاسلحه تطورا وهذا امريكي منذ عقود
هذا هذه الصفقه التي حدثت او لتامر
الموافقه عليها اليوم متعلقه بشراء 25
طائره افيرتي فايف السرب جديد جزء منه
مرتبط بما تم توقيعه عام 2016 بمذكره
التفاهم بين الطرفين الامريكي
بتوفير مساعده اسرائيل
بحوالي 38 مليار سنوات وبالتالي هذا جزء
من الالتزام امريكي فيما يتعلق بدعم
اسرائيل او دعم امنيه في المنطقه العربيه
دكتور خليل في ربما في زمن اخر كان يمكن
لمثل هذه الخطوه ان تشعل سباقا للتسلح بين
اسرائيل وجيرانها في المنطقه لكن هل تعتقد
ان ذلك يمكن ان يحدث في ظل حالات التطبيع
العديده التي جرت خلال الاعوام الماضيه
لا اعتقد ذلك يعني حتى لو ان هناك سباق
تصلح لن يكون على الاطلاق في قدر من
التوازي قدر من التوازن كما نعلم جميعا
كما قلت قبل قليل محمود هناك حاله تفوق
نوع الاسرئيل لديها واحد من اهم الجيوش في
العالم هو الجيش التنفي المرتبه السادسه
عالميا لديه كل انواع الاسلحه لديك ايضا
سلاح النووي الذي لا يتوفر على الاطلاق
لاي دوله في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وبالتالي
ناحيه الفوارق كبيره جدا لكن ايضا هناك
بالفعل نوع من سباق التسلح خاصه في ظل
حاله التصعيد الاقليمي بين ايران من جهه
والدول العربيه اخرى من جهه اخرى وبالتالي
هناك حاله السباق تسلل على قلعه على مستوى
الاصلاح التقليديه سواء الهجوميه او
الدفاعيه لكن بشكل عام من الصعب القول
بانه ما يحدث حاليا من شراء هذا السرب
الجديد مرتبط بسبب تسلح هناك فرق كبير جدا
لصالح اسرائيل فيما يتعلق بالاسلحه
النوعيه سواء الهجوميه او الدفاعيه
ويبقى الوضع الاقليمي حسب قراءتك هل تعتقد
فعلا ان هناك صراع كبير يمكن ان ينشف بين
اسرائيل وبين اي من دول المنطقه الكبرى
بلا شك هذا احتمال وارد جدا رغما هناك كما
نشاهد على مدار اخر كم شهر هناك حاله ما
يطلق عليه تبريد للصراعات لكنه تبريد مؤقت
في رايي الشخصي المنطقه ملتهبه جزء منه
متعلق بوجود طموحات اسرائيليه للهيمنه
بشكل او باخر وزمانه متعلق بوجود مشروع
ايراني ممتد في اكثر من العاصمه عربيه جزء
منه متعلق بوجود صراعات محليه وسرعات
اقليميه على مكنه توقع مثل الاستاذ محمود
قبل حوالي شهرين الان ان تدلع بشبه حرب
اهليه في السودان او ان تنشا مثلا حرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا وبالتالي للاسف
الشديد نحن ايذاء منطقه ملتهبه لان جذور
الصراع موجوده سواء فيما يتعلق بالمظالم
الفلسطينيه تجاه اسرائيل او فيما يتعلق
المظالم المظالم الشعوب تجاه حكامها
وبالتالي هناك دائما احتمالات لوجود صراع
اقليمي سواء كان ذلك من خلال
الملف النووي الايراني صراعات اقليميه على
النفوذه وعلى الهيمنه وبالتالي هناك وارد
جدا يحدث اي نوع من الصراع قد يكون حتى
الصراع اقليمي شامل لن يبقى لن يظهر اذا
حدث لا قدر الله
امتلاك السلاح عاده يغري باستعماله يا
دكتور خليل هل يعني في ظل هذا الحكومات
المتعاقبه في اسرائيل حكومات تنزع الى
اليمين ثم اليمين المتطرف ثم اقصى اليمين
وهكذا دواليك هل تعتقد انها في قوس الصبر
منزع او هناك مجال لمزيد من التطرف
والتطلب بعد هذه القوه التي تراكمها
الحكومات اليمنيه في اسرائيل او الحكومات
المتطرفه في اسرائيل
بلا شك الامر مرتبط بعده مسائل مساله
الاولى متعلقه دائما لو انا هناك مشكله
داخليه في اسرائيل يتم القفز من خلال
افتعال ازمه خارجيه اكثر من مره كان اخرها
قبل شهرين عندما تم توجيه ضربات الى غزه
نتيجه متطرفه ووجود صراع شبه يعني داخلي
في اسرائيل ما بين فئات فيما يتعلق بذات
الاسلحه القضائي وبالتالي كانت هناك الحل
هو القفز الاباء وافتعال ازمه خارجيه
الامر الاخر متعلق
بوجود تغذيه للصراعات وجود ايضا وهذا امر
قد لا يتحدث عنه البعض متعلق بتجار السلاح
وامراء الحروف المنطقه العربيه هؤلاء
مستفيدون بشكل كبير جدا من وجود تكبيس هذا
السلاح وبالتالي بمصلحتهم ان تلجا صراعات
كي يتم بيع السلاح وبالتالي والصلوات على
حساب الشعوب في المنطقه العربيه للاسف
الشديد دكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه كان معنا من
واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك
نهايه الحصاد الليله الكرام تصبحون على
خير
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]